good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's becoming clear that
a long trail of official negligence led
to the Valentine's Day school shooting
in parkland Florida school officials
failed so did the FBI but Broward County
Sheriff Scott Israel has a distinguished
record of exceptional ineptitude and
arrogance under Israel's leadership
Broward deputies ignored repeated
warnings about Nicholas's Cruz's violent
behavior the department received at
least 23 calls about Cruz or his family
in one call last November a tipster
specifically warned that Nicholas Cruz
was quote a school shooter in the making
which of course turned out to be sadly
true
sheriff Israel did nothing under
Israel's leadership the department
entered an agreement to drastically
reduce student arrests the goal was to
eliminate the so-called school to Prison
Pipeline which at the time was a top
priority of President Obama and Attorney
General Eric Holder the effect was a
disaster Cruz might have been arrested
and convicted of a crime were not for
that policy he would never have been
able to buy a gun
once the Parkman shooting began Israel's
deputies refused their most basic duties
deputy Scott Peterson whose only job was
to protect students at the school hid
while Cruz murdered 17 people when three
more Broward deputies arrived they too
took shelter behind their cars rather
than try and enter the school and save
the lives of children Scott Israel is
the man in charge of all of this and of
course he's responsible for it he loudly
disagrees indeed Israel relentlessly
brags about himself to all media who
will record it two years ago for example
the local newspaper in Florida reported
that Israel used tax dollars to build a
personal political machine and he
clearly had the evidence was there stone
cold confronted with it Israel said this
quote what have I done differently than
Don Shula or Abraham Lincoln or Martin
Luther King or Gandhi end quote and by
the way he said Lions don't care about
the opinions of sheep stable people
don't talk like this obviously something
is wrong with sheriff Israel as recently
as yesterday he was refusing to accept
any responsibility in the face of his
well-documented failures watch this
exchange
do you think that if the Broward
Sheriff's Office had done things
differently this shooting might not have
happened
listen if ifs and buts were candy and
nuts you know
Oh J Simpson would still be in a record
books I don't know what that means
dead people and there's a whole long
list of things your department could
have done differently remarkably it got
weirder and worse from there watch are
you really not taking any responsibility
for the multiple red flags that were
brought to the attention of the Broward
Sheriff's Office about this shooter
before the incident whether it was
people near him close to him calling the
police oh I got you know Jake I could
only take responsibility for what I knew
about ie exercises my due diligence
I've given amazing leadership to this
age amazing leaders I've worked yes Jake
amazing
leadership and yet the facts suggests
that Scott Israel should not be in
charge of anything and yet he is why